if someone had those ideas today and
they were asking me about making a movie
i would tell them to stop
how do filmmakers continue to make
movies if their films aren't profitable
they can't
not from any standpoint you can't do it
if you
rely on investors and you can't do it if
you're relying on yourself financially
the best thing that i can ever recommend
is but that's why i always say i always
give
before i tell someone oh make it
yourself i tell them to learn
distribution
and learn
what your
specific film
what on average does that film kind of
make
based on a number of different factors
and then you try to stack as many of the
marketable elements into your film as
possible so that while you're being
free creatively to create whatever you
want to and to finance that
you've stacked a certain number of
things in your favor to make it
profitable if not for you for the person
that invested in the film you know
how does someone really learn
distribution though
without
really having gone through sort of the
the
heart school of hard knocks with it
that's the that's the catch-22 i think
that everything that you learn about if
you if you watch a video
and someone explains to you this is how
everything works and
that's how it worked when they made that
video because it's already changed
things that worked in 2014
don't work today
they just don't because as equipment has
become cheaper
and
the ability to market the film has
become more democratized
more people have started making films
than ever before
now
anything that you've learned leading
into this period of time
you've been able to build upon
but if you're now watching things back
then about how the industry works you
are so far behind you're so far behind
the best way that you're going to learn
is to take a certain amount of money
that you can afford to lose
get in the game
that's really the best way that you're
going to learn it if you've got a
thousand dollars
you can make a film
and i'm telling you this because i made
a film that's in distribution and it
cost me 1500 bucks
and it's on to be right now i think it's
on to me which is adam k right
that film cost me 1500 bucks and
i have a name in it you know
fair abraham who she was number one
trending on twitter at that time
uh but yeah roughly 1500 bucks is what
it cost me to make that film
you can do that and you can get into the
game
that's the best way that you're going to
learn how to do it
because
trying to
to gather that information from things
online i think you'll end up being
behind the ball when it comes to
distribution specifically when it comes
to how to write a story when it comes to
how to cast actors when it comes to how
to produce a film when it comes to
development when it comes to those
things those things
are integral to getting the film going
but the conversation that needs to
happen before that is the one that keeps
changing which is distribution
because all that affects everything else
until you get to that point
and that's the part that just keeps
changing you know
so the best way to understand it is just
shoot something
just shoot something anything
it's so cheap to do so right now
whether they have the the iphone you can
plug the little anamorphic lens adapter
for 100 bucks on the back of it and then
you're shooting something just go do it
understand
unders understanding the windows of how
to release things is important
you know
but you only learn all of those things
after you've distributed something after
you've already
invested in it or you've gotten someone
else to invest in it
so it's like
if you're
in a flight simulator or you're let's
say playing some day trading game unless
that's like your real money or you're
really flying that plane
you're not really going to learn i mean
it's going to be you're going to take
more chances and different things and so
when you really have skin in the game
it's different yeah it's very very
different it's very different and i'm
going to tell you it's so funny that
when i was making a film by committee
with you know financiers and stuff
and i would say i you know i really
believe that we should have this in the
film and and this and it would help and
i would give out all these great ideas
but it was coming from a creative
standpoint
right
and
at that time i hadn't really learned
about the marketable elements like why
this film needed to be made and why does
it need to be made this way
those are the things i didn't understand
or i should say i applied all of those
questions to
the creative part of it and not
the distribution part of it
and i had all these ideas and it was
like ah but if
if someone had those ideas today and
they were asking me about making a movie
i would tell them to stop
just
stop what you're doing right now
i'm going to explain to you why
that's not the conversation you should
have right now right now you should be
defining who is this film for and don't
say yourself
don't say yourself unless you know a lot
of people like you
and you know how to reach them
don't say that
figure out who your audience is for this
movie
because if you know who your audience is
you'll know what's important to them and
you'll know if what you're talking about
is important at all
especially if you have to spend money
because every idea you come up with all
i hear is a cash register
that's all i hear because it's going to
cost money in order to do it so just
make sure that it benefits the film
somehow financially
and if you've got enough marketable
elements sure be free go off and do you
know whatever you know in mid-sentence
make a wormhole open and the guy gets
sucked in and you know whatever i don't
whatever it is you're thinking about
doing just make sure that you've done
the homework up front to define your
audience
because that's ultimately what's going
to matter
are you able to know
the exact moment like let's say
a film is paused and re-watched or where
people drop off with your movies do you
know it to that much the analytics are
that strong for you
yes and no
uh you know it through amazon
you don't know it through the others and
that's only because you're going through
an aggregator that aggregator has that
information but they typically don't
share that information
but uh if it's if it's if it's amazon
prime you can definitely see where
people are falling off
and and and you know you'll sometimes
rack your brain wondering why why why
why at this moment and you go back and
you look at you can't see it but there's
there are things where people just they
fall off for whatever reason but yeah
you can see it you can see it i i think
in all honestly that's how
i don't i don't know if this is bad to
talk about or not but
with
netflix
people have started to become a little
bit disenchanted with the content
sometimes right
and they always say it just seems like
like there's no real connection
and i said well
there may be a reason for that
because they can see the analytics and
they can see when something drops off
maybe they think they know why
and they go back and they look and
they're like oh i see because yeah there
was before that this brunette was in it
and she walked through and then she left
the scene and then people stopped caring
so that's what we need we need more
brunettes we need more hers or whatever
that's what it was it they don't know
but they think they know because they
have they have the analytics and they're
looking at it and trying to dissect it
and figure out what any of it means
and they're doing it to such a granular
level that uh it's got to be maddening
but i think that's what they're doing i
think they're using that same
that same stuff to try to figure out how
to make movies that keep people engaged
more because ultimately that's why it
exists is for you to see and for you to
know
that people are falling off
do you think making a successful
independent film is like winning the
lottery
it depends on your definition of success
i mean if your definition of success is
you made a movie for
10 grand and made 10 million
that's definitely a lottery ticket
i don't think that there's any way that
person planned to do that
um
but my definition of success is how much
closer did i get to the vision that was
in my head when i was making the movie
how much closer did i get did i get
closer this time than i did last time
because that's a success for me and one
one day i want to be able to look at a
film and say i got exactly what was in
my head
because i you know
pleasing this guy or this lady whatever
like that that's not really
what i'm making films for what i'm
making films for is to
[Music]
to get closer and closer to the movies
that are in my head i wanna i wanna
i want to
get all the stuff that's in here on a
page and from a page on the screen
and do it in such a way where i didn't
compromise
too much
you know i didn't compromise too much
if
you know if your success is
who you got to be in the movie or who
who saw your movie and you know reached
out to you i think uh you know quentin
tarantino was trying to make reservoir
dogs as a short film and his success is
that he made it to
i want to say he said he made it to
harvey keitel or somebody and that
person was like are you crazy this
should be a feature you know that's a
success
you know you were going to make
something small and then it became huge
that could be a success it all depends
on what your definition of success is
so
that vision it sounds like has always
been there because when you went to that
one investor
who said here are my notes
and i it's my way or we don't make this
thing
you knew that no it had i really want
what was in my head to be on that screen
this isn't going to work for me well
i would say it wasn't as strong back
then the only thing i knew was that his
notes
or his new
scenes didn't fit the film
it just didn't fit the film like
to give you an example
there's a there's the people go walking
off to go look for this guy
and
he wrote in a scene where one of the
characters lady pulls up in a in a jeep
and they're like oh how'd you go back
and get the jeep and she's like well my
father used to race you know jeeps back
in the day through the desert and like
what does that have to do with anything
it was just it was the most
useless piece of piece of backstory and
why would they have a vehicle if they
had a vehicle then they could just leave
like it was just it opened the thing for
like why it doesn't make sense in this
film
and that was the reason why i didn't
want it in the film not because it
wasn't part of my vision
but because it just didn't fit in the
film and none of the things that he
wrote fit in the film
now i would say if if someone comes to
me and they can give me very sound
advice i had it on the previous film
where somebody came to me and they said
i just
i don't really get this and then we
talked about it and i realized
wow
from a really objective sense
your idea does work better than my idea
you know and so we we took that idea and
incorporated it into the film so i'm not
so much about um
[Music]
being so vain as to say my way is the
only way but i believe there should be
one voice
that one voice should ring very clear
throughout the film
and along the way because it's a
collaborative process
there'll be times when someone will have
advice for you that really
makes that moment way more honest
than the one you created
and you have to take that advice as the
voice you know that that advice is good
sound advice
but it can't just be shoved into the
film because
this guy said so
because it can really take people out of
the film